on soir gilbert collard merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france le
comportement des français qui est donc à
la clé de la réussite selon jean castex
qui souligne qu' un certain relâchement
a été remarqué ces derniers jours
qu'elle est notre réaction là dessus
c'est vrai qu'on compte beaucoup sur les
français pour la réussite de ce
déconfinement écouter on a vraiment
l'impression que depuis le début de
cette sinistre pandémie les français
sont des otages des cobayes
on se sert d'eux pour finalement testé
dans la chair rendant dans la souffrance
dans la vie la manière dont il faut soit
dans un premier temps ne rien faire soit
dans un deuxième temps confinés soir
dans un troisième temps des confiné tout
en précisant qu on pourrait être amené à
reconfigurer en réalité il s'agit d'un
déconfinement purement cyniquement
économique et qu'il produira ses fruits
vénéneux par le retour au confinement
dans quelques temps parce que le virus
n'est pas parti et tant qu'on n'aura pas
les gels tant qu'on n'aura pas à les
masquer entre eux n'aura pas le vaccin
on fera courir à la population un risque
réel donc je je crois vraiment que des
français sans les otages de leurs
gouvernements et les cobayes du
confinement et du déconfinement et que
c'est sur le repos que tout va se jouer
finalement alors gilbert collard qu'est
ce qu'il aurait fallu faire aujourd'hui
en tout cas maintenant quand ronny mais
c'est trop tard finalement il aurait
fallu rester confiné en attendant enfin
l'arrivée de ces tests massifs qui ont
certainement fait d'efforts notamment
écouter donne d'abord il aurait fallu qu
en décembre quand le président de la
république savait que l'ennemi mortel
était sur le territoire qu'ils le disent
j'arrive pas à comprendre comment et en
informer à ce moment-là de la présence
du virus
il ne l'a il n'a pas dit et comment ils
n'ont pas pris
ils le gouvernement à l'ensemble des
responsables à la fois politique et
administratif ils n'ont pas pris les
mesures nécessaires pour que nous ayons
en temps utile les mars que le gel et
tout le matériel nécessaire
je pense qu'on aurait dû de attendre
pour des confiné faire un déconfinement
purement économique sur les zones
stratégiques éviter d'envoyer les
enfants à l'école parce que je pense que
ça va être très grave de conséquences vu
qu'on a affaire à un virus qu'on ne
connaît pas et je crois qu'entre la
bourse et la vie si vous voulez il faut
toujours choisir la vie et j'ai peur que
ce gouvernement est voulu choisir et la
bourse et la vie et des conséquences je
le crains seront seront dramatiques je
suis très pessimiste quant aux
conséquences de ce déconfinement gilbert
collard vous dit le gouvernement aurait
dû le dire ça veut dire quoi
concrètement
qui ne l'a pas dit par un mensonge par
omission qu'il la sous-estimer tout
simplement selon vous de cette blague
quand on dit oui là je comprends mais
excusez ma réaction spontanée réaction
de demander sur surprise quand on est le
chef de l'état et qu'on apprend qu'il y
à un ennui mortel sur le territoire on
doit le dire parce que guru en admettant
qu'on veuille ne pas le dire pour ne pas
affoler les populations au prendre les
mesures
on recommande les masques on commande le
gel on déploie toutes les mesures dans
les hôpitaux on prend les mesures en
l'occurrence on a tourné des élections
municipales à la place et on maintient
les élections municipales voilà bon de
dire que tout cela arrivera devant une
cour pénale je vous l'autre parce que
les morts ne pardonne pas et je pense
qu'on a qu'on a affaire à des amateurs
quoi vraiment on l'a dit on est en
guerre mais c'est la 7ème compagnie qui
va au combat quoi on a affaire à des
amateurs qui un jour disent oui un jour
10 dans tout à l'heure j'entendais
le monsieur déconfinement vous arriver à
comprendre ce qui veut dire quand il dit
il faut que les français comprennent
pourquoi on dit oui pourquoi on dit non
le zoo ça veut dire quoi on va écouter
gilbert collard edouard philippe qui
donne peut-être un début d'explication
pour lui il faut justement trouvé un bon
équilibre entre risques sanitaires et
déconfinement crête sur lequel nous nous
trouvons est un chemin qui nous impose
de tenir un équilibre entre la sécurité
sanitaire et la reprise entre les deux
c'est un équilibre
c'est toujours difficile de maintenir un
équilibre mais vous voyez bien et vous
savez pertinemment que si nous donnons
la priorité à l'un en oubliant l'autre
nous risquons de très mauvaises
nouvelles de très mauvaises nouvelles
vous savez parfaitement monsieur le
président la catastrophe sociale qui
s'annonce et qui serait encore pire si
nous restions indéfiniment confiné vous
le savez vous la vivez dans votre
département enfin tout le monde la vie
tout le monde la santé on la voit
arriver nous devons donc reprendre la
production
nous devons donc reprendre la vie
sociale nous devons donc reprendre
l'école parce que sinon c'est la
catastrophe
et nous savons aussi que si nous allons
trop vite par enthousiasme par
imprudence en privilégiant cette fois ci
la reprise sur la sécurité sanitaire
nous risquons dans ce cas là de très
mauvaises nouvelles sanitaires et
gilbert collard tout même vous
n'accordez pas un petit peu de bon sens
à ce que vient de déclarer le premier
ministre
d'abord d'abord je n'arrive pas à
comprendre qu'on puisse assimiler la
fonction politique à celle d'un d'un
funambule parce que dessous le fil en
bus il ya toujours le fracas du vide
franchement la métaphore est pour le
moins effrayante qu'il y ait un
impératif économique
on est tous conscients il faudrait être
complètement abrutis pont ne pas se
rendre compte que la situation
économique est dramatique et qu'il faut
réagir
l'économie aussi mais faut-il le faire
dans cette précipitation
faut-il le faire sans organisation parce
que on parle de la reprise de l'activité
dans les écoles mais les écoles ne sont
pas prêtes on parle de la reprise de
l'activité dans les entreprises mais
c'est encore sur les épaules des chefs
d'entreprise que tout repose on sait
même pas comment la sncf va pouvoir
organiser les transports alors qu'elle
dit elle même que si elle doit respecter
la distanciation exiger les transports
ne sont plus rentables enfin il ya un
chaos
alors je comprends tout à fait qu'il
faille sauver l'économie mais pas au
prix des vies et là encore on est dans
une désorganisation qui relève de
l'amateurisme
je pense qu'on aurait dû procéder par
étapes en fonction des secteurs
économiques est essentielle en
organisant une protection en s'y prenant
bien évidemment à l'avance dans ces
secteurs clé mais là et en plus y'a rien
il ya défaut grave de pédagogie
les françaises et les français ont
l'impression que c'est les vacances que
les volets s'ouvrent les fenêtres
s'ouvrent le soleil va entrer dans les
vies et qu'on peut recommencer à aller
voir les copains a craqué à se
rencontrer
alors que le virus y est là l'ennemi est
là tapie et il attend bon on aurait dû
vraiment préparé ce déconfinement avec
une une une volonté de d'informer de de
tram attisé même pour forcer les
réflexes de précaution qui n'existe pas
on le voit les gens s'imaginent que
c'est le 14 juillet le feu d'artifice en
ce n'est pas ce que dit exactement
jackass est justement qu'il met en garde
les français une dernière question
gilbert collard mais robert dont il
aimait rockeur l'institut montaigne un
proche du patronat préconise aujourd'hui
des journées de travail plus longues à
jour férié supprimé une semaine de
vacances scolaires en moins recours
accru au forfait jours dans la fonction
publique ça ce sera pour après pour
rattraper
les pertes économiques votre réaction
mais je propose une diminution des
bénéfices du cac 40 des grandes
entreprises des compagnies d'assurance
des banques
il n'y a aucune raison que ce soit le
citoyen ordinaire qui après avoir servi
d'otages de cobayes viennent faire faire
faire l'esclave financier de la
situation mais c'est trop facile
c'est vraiment absolument inacceptable
merci gilbert collard rappelle que vous
êtes député européen rassemblement
national merci d'avoir été en direct
avec nous